It's been a really good start to 2016 from the point of view of the periodic
table,
are you pack the international union of pure and applied chemistry has
confirmed the existence of four new elements.
So if you look at the periodic table here,
we have elements 113, 115,
117, 118 that have no names at the moment.
They have symbols. You U P meaning one, one, five,
but they don't have a real name.
And what's happened is not new experiments,
but the committees looking at the experimental evidence have
decided that those elements really have been synthesized
and a real so in a way,
it's a bit like giving a prize to the people.
Who've done the experiments to say,
you've got it right before we go into possible names for these elements.
Let me just remind you if you haven't watched our videos before,
how you make these elements. If you look at the periodic table,
all the elements that are heavier than uranium, number 92,
all of these are highly radioactive.
And as you go along the periodic table, they become more and more radioactive.
Even if you have some atoms,
they decay in fractions of a second or just a few seconds.
So you can't take them out to the ground. You have to make them.
And the way you make them is by taking a lighter item,
which is still quite heavy and bombarding that
material with lighter atoms, you do this. So billions of lights,
atoms hit every second. And then every so often,
perhaps once a week for difficult elements, once a month,
one of these atoms fuses into the other one.
So you can see it's quite a hard process and my dog toys getting a bit old.
So now you have a combined nucleus. For example,
we have element 95, I'm a research team.
Plus element co SIM 2020 plus
95 makes 115 and bingo,
you get an atom of the element because this atom is quite
unstable. So you detect it by watching it decay.
These elements here have been discovered in different labs
usually, but not always as a collaboration between two different
laboratories.
And you have to understand that these are such specialized experiments,
that you will only find one suitable lab in a particular country.
And often, most countries don't even have such labs.
So element 113 was first discovered in the lab in
Japan.
We have a video in Japanese about it for our Japanese so-so
[inaudible] and the other elements. Yeah, one, one, five, one, one seven one,
one eight work collaborations between us lab and
the research center in Dubai now near Moscow.
And so the experiments were done in [inaudible]
, but the precursors, the radioactive materials, like berkelium, which were the heavy element that we crushed into were prepared in America and flown over.
Now you have to understand that the way that our U pike operates is
that after the first lab has done the experiments,
they require somebody else to do the repeat of the experiments to make
sure the first ones are bright. So, although for example,
I might have done the first experiments I don't synthesize and elements,
but just as an example,
then somebody else will confirm my results.
So it's only polite.
And I think nice to talk to the other people before choosing a name,
there's certain rules. You can name it after places, countries,
people,
but the important thing is the person has to be a scientist.
Who's dead. My feeling is, and I have no idea what the name's going to be,
but I think element one, one,
three is likely to have a Japanese name because
the Japanese library Reichen has been told they can choose the name.
There is a fruit which some of you may know called japonica.
So you could imagine a name,
something like japonica based on Japan,
it would have the simple JP J doesn't appear on the periodic
table yet. So that would be really nice.
First sometimes Germans call ID by the letter
J but most periodic tables don't have a J there is some
internet chatter, and I've heard rumors that element one, one,
five will be called Moscow Vivian after Moscow.
I think that will be really good. Then of course,
the symbol M O has already gone for molybdenum.
I like Muskogee because my father was born in Moscow.
I have also suggested that element one,
one seven should be called after Richard Fineman,
the famous physicist find Manian.
But some viewers already said that find
Manian should be left for element 132,
which find month predicted might be stable. So we'll have to see,
I feel probably that the most thoughts will be given by
people two elements, 118,
because that's the highest number currently on the
periodic table.
And I have no idea what they will choose. You will see all over the press.
People are saying the periodic table is now complete,
which in a way it is that we've finished this row of the
periodic table, the seventh row, as you go down one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven.
But I see this just as a beginning, the field is now open.
Can physicists now synthesize elements,
which will start row number eight down here.
The first element that's likely to be synthesized is one,
120,
because even numbered elements are more stable than odd numbered
elements.
And so it will be really interesting to see whether one of
these elements can be made. Soon.
Periodic table is always waiting for new results. In fact,
we already have a video about the possibility of element 120,
which you can watch. If you're interested,
chemistry is not finished. This is just the beginning.
And I hope that 2016 is going to be a really exciting year for
chemistry and for science in general. So again,
happy new year to you all great success in your science and keep working.
[Inaudible] [inaudible].